i have 100 000 in cash in the best
minecraft players in the entire world
dream has broken the minecraft speedrun
world record
three times he is the fastest growing
youtube channel on the platform and
widely regarded as the best minecraft
player and dream will be going up
against technoblade four-time champion
of minecraft monday techno won
1400 games of bed wars in a row this man
even beat minecraft
with the steering wheel and these two
behemoths will be going head-to-head for
100
000 in this corner right here we have
dream
how's it going man i'm ready i was born
ready yeah dream
what are you gonna do if you end up
losing i'm gonna cry
dream you suck techno's winning don't
talk about my friend like that
you're stealing carl away from me he
bought your merch
and in the other corner is technoblade
yeah techno you got this this better not
hurt my dream
yay so this is a best of 10 series they
will be fighting 10 times and whoever
wins six matches first wins and to keep
things fair every duel we're gonna be
rotating game modes techno mains
minecraft 1.8 whereas dream means the
newest version
we have three insane maps that these
minecraft gods will be duking it out on
this will be
peak epicness chandler hey here's a coin
if it lands on heads the first game is
1.8 tails is the newest version
1.8 okay the coin landed on heads which
means the first duel is
1.8 yeah techno home field advantage
dream doesn't even need it dream are you
ready yes
yeah techno are you ready yeah
this map is called genesis and this is
where our first stool will be taking
place
starting to one five and the duel
has now begun come on techno why was he
just standing there
a hundred grand on the line reputation
on the line everything i've never seen
people battle with fishing poles
because it makes you knock back that's
the thing oh techno's already down
look at it's like it's evenly matched oh
my gosh on the advance
yeah dream has like a half a heart extra
how are you oh dream so
three three
oh my gosh oh my gosh techno won the
first duel techno you're incredible
i can't get 10 0's now guys
he was trying to like position himself
at the side and i'm like get out of here
nerd i'm just gonna sit here
oh my god the stretch dream no
you lost the first tool what happened
it's fine it's fine that's his version
he can he can take the dub i'll get back
out of here stop putting your head down
dream no
you're gonna drop that crown of yours
okay king techno you are currently up
one game you got this if you win another
one you beat dream on his home field
and then you can pretty much win it's a
it's over from there we have now
switched versions and kits so this next
game is actually gonna be on dream's
home field technoblade's already ready
he's confident dream this is now your
version
by all means you should get the dub here
he's done a lot of training he'll be a
admirable opponent but i should this is
your game to lose he's been practicing
three hours a day
they made hours that small all right
gentlemen gentlemen sember down
simperdom
dream are you ready i'm ready the fight
has began
dream is coming out hot they're just
looking at each other dream's got this
i'm not even concerned no one's going
for each other yet yes techno with the
wow what holy cow this is close oh my
god
yeah dream got the dumb dream
okay it is now time what dude anyone
else's hand sweating and you're not even
playing that is what we do
dream it's a reset it's a it's a reset
and i'll get to beat him in his own
version how much help did he have oh
full
don't even worry about it yes this next
arena is named chungus valley techno's
got this
and it's currently tied someone's going
to walk away from this oh you mean
techno is going to walk away from this
up the most riveting gameplay in the
world fishing
oh dream's going in oh dreams up all
right it's tied they both have lost two
hearts it's tied take no blade's backing
off
oh oh what is this stalemate what is
this holy [ __ ] dreams up a heart now oh
stream is up a heart stream is currently
up come on techno you got this
i didn't go to fedex this morning to get
this shirt for nothing all right dream
has full health techno's down
one i am so nervous everything is on the
line oh no can't
lose on his own blades still take those
down
oh my gosh oh
i could not have been closer he's insane
techno never dies
hector you are currently up again two
times i can only get eight two to now
oh yeah are you kidding me half a heart
techno you are currently up
what's going through your mind i hope i
win more rounds in the future
what are you talking about you got this
keep that doubt in your brain
round four all right techno could change
the tide here
no we can they are back on the newest
version of minecraft as you can tell
they have shields and everything he's
mining he's trolling
techno's face in his head could you
imagine
literally 1v1 in minecraft for a hundred
thousand dollars
oh oh oh my gosh no dream oh
holy
oh my gosh oh my god take no
you're making him look like he was a
child my heart is about to explode out
of my
chest one of the best players in the
world where is this coming from i'm not
half bad myself
i mean i could tell what the heck dream
buddy buddy it's good it's good this man
is the warriors he's about to blow this
lead
all right
okay round five
and the third arena they will be dueling
in is the glorious krusty krab
castle all right it's starting techno
has three wins stream has one like i
said it's best of ten dude look how
aggressive dream speech
not playing around techno's up two
hearts oh my goodness oh my goodness oh
my goodness oh
dream can't see the hearts and he
doesn't know that he's losing oh no oh
no
oh they both have my heart oh my god oh
my gosh
oh they both have one heart
you both literally had one heart and
just ran at each other
and you came out on top you were down
two to three hearts i told you dream was
clutch
how much health was he at he had one
heart
round six alright we are back on dreams
version with shields
by all means dream should win this and
tie it up you know in dragon ball z
oh oh
it's looking up it's looking up oh no
techno
no dream is just obliterating him okay
okay dreams up two hearts oh no no
no no it's not even a question this time
dream only lost two hearts okay it is
now tied
3-3 you are a king you are a king dream
i bet you feel very relieved now that
it's tight again oh
my god i'm so relieved now that it's 3-3
back when you are down one to three did
you think you might have lost
i always have confidence in myself jimmy
it was pretty close though
i finished with like seven health or
something or six health it's the most
health anyone's finished one of these
duels with all right let's go check on
tech note
techno that was a given it was his game
mode it's now tied up again
tide is good i like ties 100 grand on
the line tied 3-3
are you ready i'm ready all right good
luck
all right here it goes up wait guys we
forgot to have chandler announce the
round
that was my favorite part techno is
standing by his word
and throwing that fishing hook he's
using that rod like he said he would oh
dream no dream yes yes stream go down
oh tag goes up hard techno's up too hard
oh
yes no wow no
you reclaimed the lead i just praised
jesus and i'm not even a christian
that's how happy i am
that was incredible how is this so back
and forth
it's so close dream you're currently
down by one obviously next round did
your version
we'll keep it short and sweet anything
you have to say nope all right
round eight yeah whoa it's back
baby
carl go give dream a pep talk and let
him know we're ready chris
yeah give techno a pep talk let no we're
ready he doesn't need it but i'll do it
anyway
jimmy i'll give you a pep talk where are
you they told me to come in here and
give you a pep talk i don't even think
you need it
you're set you're up one you're ready to
win b
dream at his own game it's only a
hundred grand don't be too sad thank you
thank you techno is currently in the
lead
can dream tie it up again no he can't if
dream wins this he wins the whole thing
mark my words yeah this could be the
last game
so they're they're doing the titty tatty
oh oh no hey dream reached and dream got
punished oh
stream down no dreams down like three
hearts so this is his version oh tecmo
down somehow he just came back
dream knows what he's doing oh oh oh oh
oh oh oh he knows
what he's doing he knows what he's doing
he knows what he's doing
you're going all the way dream i told
you you win that one you win the whole
thing
tied up four four i think i think i
i think i broke my mic stand but tens of
thousands of dream stands across the
world are watching
yes we are carl said yes we are carl's
such a tier three synth oh my god
techno what are your thoughts on the
last duel i think i was in the lead but
then at the end i gave up on the axe
crits and you you just can't give up on
the axe crits it's just not how you win
the game
you were in the lead by two hearts at
once i was like oh my gosh
i thought you were about to win and then
somehow he just pulled it out
round nine techno if you win this
and it's your version at the very least
you'll get a tie and you can't lose all
you have to do is win this and you can't
lose
dream if he wins this one it's at least
a tie for him i don't want him to be
that happy
i want you to be that happy all right
we're ready when you are good luck
i'm so stressed and it has nothing to do
with me
dream is ready is techno ready yep all
right here we go two rounds remain
tied four four we are about to find out
who the best minecraft player
in the entire world is 100 grand on the
line let's see what happens oh my gosh
techno don't choke he's going in oh no
techno's down two already all right he's
regen he's running he's reginning
jeremy has to know that he's rejecting
he has to know that dream has a full two
heart lead now it's down to one heart
i'm so nervous i'm about to poop my
pants i can't even describe it oh my
gosh
okay back to full hearts all right what
is about to happen techno
is doing the good old baby roof oh that
arrow was so close
techno just picked up that arrow oh my
gosh it's so close
oh no dream dream oh no yes oh
no no techno can't lose techno can't
lose take note now has five wins
and we have one round remaining all he
has to do is win the next one and he
wins
dude techno oh my goodness
oh my god my heart that was so close you
have now won
five of the ten rounds you can't lose
the worst you can do is draw now
i used the rod i just had to remember
calvin's teachings
use the rod it's the way i can't even
think
all you have to do is just win the next
one and you win a hundred grand
all i have to do is not get owned by
dreams epic axe crits
if you win the next one a hundred grand
is being deposited into your bank
account
oh dude at least 12 pizzas
all right that's all dream no it was
close it was close
this is the 10th and final round if you
lose this
techno has six wins and wins if you win
this it's a 5-5 tie
so close down to the wire what is going
through your head dream
i came back from 3-1 down i feel pretty
good i want to get this tie
guys i don't think we need to ramble
anymore let's do this let's let the axes
speak for themselves
let's see who the best player on earth
is
this is the final one all right dream
last round baby you got this you
we're ready when you're ready all right
techno it's the last round
there's literally zero pressure you
can't lose i believe in you
let's tie this bad boy up all you have
to do is beat
him at his own game and you win a
hundred grand and are deemed the best
minecraft player in the world
dream is ready techno it's starting oh
this is the final oh
the tenth and final duel is upon us dude
the last round
will techno claim the title of the best
minecraft player on planet earth
techno was so calm so cool look he
doesn't care
trolling yeah he's oh oh wait was that
dream
oh no all right all right all right oh
oh they're both full health
oh my gosh oh they're they're playing
around the rosie
ring around the rosie get hit by dream
oh they're even right now dream
down three hearts no oh no oh
dream down no no okay the times are
turning
no what no way no way
no oh my goodness
techno congratulations you just won
a hundred thousand dollars i genuinely
cannot process this
dude that practice and paid off congrats
techno
you outplayed me you did amazing thank
you you did you did really well as well
i'm gonna be honest i thought i was
gonna lose so it's not gonna lie this
was a very epic fight
i'm glad you guys both can still be
friends and i think we should express to
the viewers that like this was for fun
absolutely yeah no bead no i hate techno
but i hate him so much i hate that guy
no drama things are good techno
congratulations i will wire you 100 000
and thank you so much everybody for
watching we'll see you in the next video